dire un vrai ami ne m'aurait pas fait ça
et voilà quelqu'un qui vous enfle d'un
tel montant je suis désolé mais au bout
d'un moment il faut le dire voilà je
suis et c'est très regrettable et je ça
me fait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vers 3h40 du matin 4h on pénétré dans le
domicile de l'animateur il habite à
Tessancourt sur aubette dans les
Yvelines Gilles c'est comment c'est une
petite commune au nord des Yvelines dans
le Vexin d'accord un des Mureaux voilà
d'accord un petit village et il y a sa
maison là-bas à côté c'est comment les
parce qu'on m'a dit que voilà il y a
quoi à côté c'est c'est
voilà alors il y a un petit côté rural
il y a un petit côté plus agité on va
dire ça voilà un petit côté plus agité
un petit côté plus compliqué à côté
alors les intrus ont donc cassé une
vitre d'une chambre d'amis donc une
chambre qui était pas où il y avait
personne située au rez-de-chaussée avant
de se rendre dans la chambre parentale
où se trouvait l'animateur de France 2
et sa femme qui était dans leur lit
alors déjà une chambre d'amis située au
rez-de-chaussée où il y avait personne
David ça c'est comme tu disais c'est
quelqu'un qui a donné le nom et puis
comme ce que vient de dire Gilles comme
il y a un truc un quartier s'agit d'à
côté le bouche-à-oreille vous voyez le
le passage il suffit que déjà il le
voyait en voiture il le voit chez lui
tout ça c'est en fait ce qu'il se passe
c'est que les cambrioleurs les brokers
ils ont le temps ils ont le temps pour
eux qui jouent pour eux qui
se sont fait réveiller comme ça c'est ça
Reda les mecs avaient des infos oui
souvent ils ont des infos on a
régulièrement aussi pour les gens qui
font les marcher on sait que dans
certains quartiers on donne des primes à
des gens qui balancent des gens qui
travaillent dans les marchés parce
qu'ils savent que dans les la plupart
des gens qui travaillent dans les
marchés de l'espèce exactement
le bouche-à-oreille comme un dit
Monsieur et puis c'est des réseaux qui
sont de délinquants au profil on voit de
plus en plus de profils surtout de de
banlieue de quartier malheureusement au
vu de la description des individus ça
semble être le cas des individus
masque la mode le masque chirurgical et
puis la capuche assez jeune 4 à 5
individus 4 à 5 individus donc ils se
sont introduits dans la maison sans
produit dans la maison ça a été très
très violent ils ont donc là ils ont la
sortie une arme de points c'est pas un
cambriolage il faut préciser parce que
c'est important là c'est du criminel
c'est un voilà maramé d'accord un bande
organisé avec séquestration d'accord
alors on va on va rappeler ce qui s'est
passé donc 3h40 du matin vous imaginez
bien vous êtes réveillés
par donc 4 ou 5 hommes avec des masques
chirurgicaux d'accord ils mettent l'arme
sur la tempe du de Bruno Guillaume
monsieur ouais de l'animateur donc lui
il est dans son lit tout à fait les
sortes du lit une arme sur la tempe si
on fait comme on dit j'aime avoir cet
effet de surprise pour que ce soit
violent il faut que les gens soient
surpris c'est-à-dire qu'il est pas un
temps de réflexion la seule réflexion
voilà il se réveille enfin il se
réveille choqué avec une arme avec sa
femme ses enfants ils sont séparés les
enfants l'enfant se retrouve avec la
mère dans la chambre la jambe la chambre
de l'enfant ils sont attachés donc là la
la ils sont les deux dans la chambre
il rejoignent le petit et puis après il
il y a deux individus qui qui isolent la
mer et le fils
les attachent et ensuite ils demandent
les bijoux les numéraires faire l'argent
le petit
ils ont détaché la mer ils ont détaché
la mer pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
l'emmener dans les lieux où il y a les
bijoux pour l'emmener au coffre pour
qu'elle vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
justement c'est la spécificité de genre
de mes fesses et que le fait d'avoir les
propriétaires vous pouvez ouvrir le coq
ou plus facilement que si ils étaient
pas là du coup elle donne les numéros et
ensuite elle appelle la police alors ça
a duré combien de temps a priori à peu
près 15 minutes ça va très très vite
mais quinze minutes pour des victimes
sur nous garantir que c'est très
extrêmement long c'est extrêmement long
alors il y a eu des violences Gilles oui
il est alors ils les ont menacé déjà
avec armes de poing et marteau c'est ça
qui fait frémir aussi
et il leur demande donc d'aller au
coffre et pour récupérer les bijoux
voilà évidemment pour pas être connu
parler la grâce donc c'est des équipes
spécialisées et puis ils emmènent la
femme de Bruno Guillon vers le coffre
pour qu'elle ouvre le coffre mural voilà
et la menace avec marteau évidemment et
armes de poing c'est si vous n'ouvrez
pas voilà ce qu'il y a eu des violences
ou pas du tout il y a pas eu de violence
physique je crois sauf erreur vous
mettez sur la tente on est au niveau du
violon
c'est parce que vous voyez votre vie
défilé vous avez votre enfant à côté
vous avez votre femme vous avez rien
demandé et
en général
contrairement enfin comme disait
monsieur je sais pas s'il disait tout à
fait ça mais c'est plus la même
génération de de cambrioleur de
braqueurs c'est c'est devenu très très
violent il y a plus de respect pour la
famille il y a plus de respect pour la
police non plus donc 3h40 du matin donc
quatre ou cinq hommes pénètre dans le
domicile de Bruno Guillon et il
repartent à trois heures 53 du matin
aucune violence figue n'ont été constaté
par bien sûr ce que vous avez dit mais
évidemment bien sûr Bruno Guillon sa
femme et son fils son état de choc le
butin est important montre de luxe
bijoux environ 80.000 euros Gilles je
crois deux montres de luxe selon mes
informations mais c'est encore à
détailler de la maroquinerie de luxe
voilà autour de 80000 euros je crois que
c'est deux montres qui qui va le
chercher pas si vous avez le détail je
pense qu'il y a on n'a pas encore le
détail parce que c'est ça la
problématique sur ce genre d'affaires
c'est c'est les victimes qui sont très
choquées vous pouvez avoir dans la
soirée ou dans les jours à venir un
retour sur expérience
se rendre compte qu'il y a eu ça ça il y
a peut-être un individu de plus on a
remarqué tel ou telle chose c'est
l'enquête de voisinage qui est très très
important vous avez parlé des
descriptions des des individus c'est
quoi c'est c'est des personnes qui
parlaient français ce sont des quoi
c'est oui moi je sais que à chaque fois
que je fais un plateau j'aime bien
prendre la tâche avec les collègues des
services concernés enfin là c'est pas le
service parce que là il c'est la BRB qui
a été saisie d'accord quand vous avez
une affaire pas basique séquestration
n'est jamais basique mais à partir du
moment où vous avez une pluralité
d'auteur une
usage d'une arme enfin l'exhibition
d'une arme pardon et surtout que c'est
une personnalité automatiquement ou
basculer judiciairement parlant dans une
moquette prioritaire donc c'est à dire
que là vous avez le parquet vous avez
les officiers de police judiciaires de
la brigade de répression du banditisme
qui est qui soit qui reste avec le même
substitut du procureur qui va traiter
l'affaire de A à Z c'est même collègues
sont en contact tout le temps avec les
victimes qui sont très choqués pour les
rassurer pour leur dire que l'enquête
avance et ou pas et du coup vous vous
enquêtez vous faites l'enquête de
voisinage et ce qui est très important
quand vous arrivez sur les lieux c'est
des policiers de voie publique qui
arrivent sur les lieux ils doivent
préserver les traces de indices parce
qu'à partir du moment où il y a
l'arrivée des pompiers qui peuvent pas
contre les pompiers mais c'est très
important de préserver bien sûr malgré
les chocs les lieux et la police
scientifique elle va apporter des
éléments très très important si vous
faites une enquête normale ces quatre à
six mois dans ce genre d'affaires si
vous avez des indices ADN et c'est là
que c'est important les la présence de
la pollution le travail de la police
technique et scientifique c'est que si
vous avez des prélèvements ADN en 15
jours vous pouvez boucler la faire mais
est-ce qu'il y a une description des
individus assez précise ou pas du tout
écouter on sait qu'il y a un individu
nord-africain casquette c'est de s'avère
d'être des jeunes de quartier tout
simplement donc voilà après on peut pas
donner trop de détails parce que ça se
trouve il nous regarde même ce soir donc
ils l'ont parlé ils leur ont dit quoi
alors en général ce sont des gens qui
sont comme il y a plus de code
sont des gens qui sont très violents
verbalement et très menaçant et dans ces
cas-là vous pensez en général quand vous
avez un enfant vous pensez qu'à votre
enfant en fait vous posez pas de
question vous donnez vous leur donnez
tout ce qu'ils veulent tout simplement
très organisée moi j'ai une question par
rapport à l'heure Cyril vous soulignez
trois heures quarante départ à 3h53
Bruno Guillon c'est quelqu'un qui se
lève tôt pour aller travailler donc ça
veut dire que sans doute ils avaient
repéré ils savaient qu'ils avaient un
lap de temps assez court pour intervenir
avant qu'il se lève et qui partent et
que vous pensez que c'est le cas donc de
nombreuses nuits de repérage également
alors maintenant on a des équipes qui
sont avec la télé avec les séries qui
sont très très organisées il y a même
des équipes qui posent des balises sur
les véhicules des victimes et c'est à
dire qu'il est suivie pendant plusieurs
jours plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs
mois des balises sur les véhicules des
Bali GPS pour savoir exactement pourquoi
ils ont pas attendu et c'est vrai que
c'est que même que limite à limite que
Bruno Lyon partent puisqu'il part très
tôt il a l'air matinal avec parce que
citizol la femme mais toi à sa place si
on isole ta femme et ton fils dans une
pièce c'est la responsabilité de ta
famille tu vas balancer tout de suite
parce que si tu fais le malin et que tu
entends deux coups de feuilles
exactement c'est important de le
signaler parce que c'est vrai que c'est
quand même c'est donc qu'ils avaient
énormément d'infos c'est David c'est un
truc ça c'est un truc qui a été donné
c'est pour ça que les infos voilà moi
pour moi c'est un truc qui c'est un truc
qui était prémédité à l'avance euh
longtemps tu penses que quoi ils ont mis
quoi 15 jours à travailler sur le
dossier des fois même plus hein
les préparations après bon c'est minimum
15 jours mais comment ils peuvent savoir
qu'il y a un butin ça marquer des buts
il y a des bijoux comment ils savent pas
en 80 000 euros c'est qu'ils ont fait un
gros repérage ouais après il y a surtout
le côté notoriété le côté star le côté
donc il se doute un peu après et il y a
même le coup peut être donné encore plus
plus ça peut être des intimes ça va ça
va très loin des gens qui peuvent même
dire il a un coffre il a il a tel truc
tel truc ça vous savez
je vais pas vous l'apprendre mais il
faut avoir confiance en personne quoi
c'est
beaucoup de des gens qui vous entourent
peuvent donner des des coûts des gens
que vous pensez être votre ami et vos
amis vous faites rentrer
faut jamais avoir de coffres chez soi
planqué bijoux et argent dans des
endroits improbables pas de coffre ça
attire les mouches c'est vrai ça c'est
coffre c'est vrai que moi
c'est vrai que voilà mais là pour le
coup il y a pour le coup là même sans
coffre parce que
ibrac bien sûr
ils disent oui il a cachette n'importe
qui pour ceux et sa famille dit oui il a
plaquette les individus ils vont plus
ils vont montrer qui sont déséquilibrés
qu'ils ont peur de rien et qui sont
vulgaires qui sont violents plus la
personne va se dire bon je vais pas
jouer même si j'ai de l'argent là je
vais le donner parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils sont excusez-moi il y a plus de
code ils sont un peu stupides les bijoux
on peut pas les retrouver parce que ça
va être écoulé assez rapidement ça ça
appartient les bijoux bah écoutez il y a
différents réseaux ça va l'économie on a
laissé vous savez je vais pas faire
refaire le sujet qu'on a fait il y a
quelques temps mais on a de plus en plus
de mal à avoir de la présence policière
sur la République parce qu'il y a
d'autres priorités du coup
le marché parallèle se développe de plus
en plus on l'a vu avec par exemple les
mortiers les gars ils sont équipés alors
que c'est on peut plus les vendre en
France aucun artifice est vendable en
France et pour autant ils arrivent à
avoir des mitraillettes 390 coups sur
sur du mortier donc là c'est pareil en
fait vous avez du marché parallèle qui
peut après finalement peut-être finir en
Europe sur des raisons en Europe mais là
déjà vous avez une demande déjà dans les
quartiers où les gens aiment bien se
balader avec des véhicules de luxe
porter des vêtements de luxe avoir des
sacs à main de luxe c'est la nouvelle
génération et c'est la nouvelle
génération d'un délinquance également
c'est quoi ça peut être la voiture le
véhicule peut-être il a un véhicule qui
a qui a mis la puce à l'oreille ou bien
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît qui a donné
le alors moi ce qu'on m'a dit
éventuellement et je voulais que je
voulais confirmer avec vous deux je sais
par exemple c'est des collègues à vous
qui m'ont dit il y a récemment une
présentatrice d'une chaîne de télé
carbore et des bijoux à l'antenne qui a
attiré l'attention qui a été suivie
jusqu'à chez elle et cambrioler est-ce
qu'il n'a pas pu être suivi en voiture
depuis l'antenne parce que on m'a évoqué
ce cas là et je me suis dit il pouvait y
avoir des similitudes suivre une voiture
jusqu'à chez lui une bande organisée
peut le faire oui en fait vous à partir
du moment où vous avez la cible vous
mettez ben c'est un peu comme nous les
policiers c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où ces individus ont la cible ils
mettent un dispositif en place
aller-retour domicile jusqu'en travail
c'est vraiment très très bien préparé
pour pas se faire attraper c'est très
très rare de faire une séquestration en
flagrant délit ça arrive mais c'est
extrêmement rare mais c'est exactement
ça mais vous avez vous avez aussi la
vengeance d'un proche comme a dit le
monsieur c'est possible d'avoir la
vengeance d'un proche ou quelqu'un de
jaloux parce que dans le dans le milieu
de la télé il y a des gens jaloux vous
avez aussi tout simplement moi j'ai
discuté avec un collègue je vais pas
dire quel service mais d'un groupe de
répression du banditisme qui m'a dit bah
il y en a parce qu'en général les
individus quand ils se présentent ils
balancent jamais les complices par
contre ils passent aux aveux
immédiatement c'est ce que m'a dit le
collègue et il m'a dit tu as fait
donner l'exemple de Di Maria c'est pas
son affaire mais tiens les gars on se
fait du mariage ce soir enfin on se fait
du Maria ce soir ou demain soir le gars
il est au match de foot sauf km de foot
et ben là c'est différent on prend sa
femme et son enfant voilà donc et dans
90 % des cas ça se passe comme ça on va
dire
c'est parce que on aimerait savoir c'est
un truc de fou qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
entre toi et notre ami Nicolas est-ce
que tu as voulu le vendre en american
staff américain staff non mais en fait
c'est très simple il y a deux ans
Nicolas pernicoff m'a commandé des
publicités pour la télé pour des marques
parce que il y a une agence de
communication il m'a commandé en
production des publicités des contenus
pour les marques à hauteur de 165.000
euros et il ne m'a jamais payé voilà
c'est très simple ça fait deux ans qu'il
paye pas évidemment parce que j'ai vu il
y a plein de gens qui pouvaient pas
régler sans privé évidemment ça fait
deux ans qu'il y a eu des conciliations
je vais laisser un mois deux mois trois
mois six mois un an pour payer ensuite
il m'a fait un échéancier est-ce qu'on
appelle un échéancier donc quand vous
avez une dette vous divisez la dette en
10 20 30 échéances il a payé une fois
c'était une petite échéances il arrêtait
de payer donc au bout d'un moment la loi
est l'appeler parce que c'est ton pote
qui m'a appelé je l'ai vu on a fait une
conciliation avec les avocats on a fait
ça 15 fois tu vois pas qu'il fasse une
vidéo
et malheureusement je suis je déteste
faire ça et voilà mais quand on se fait
en fumée comme ça et ben faut que ça se
sache parce qu'il y a d'autres personnes
qui se sont faites en fumée et la loi
est faite de telle manière que quand
vous avez une société aujourd'hui et
c'est regrettable vous pouvez acheter si
vous avez la trésorerie 10000 1000 1
million de prestations ne jamais les
payer et vous arriverez rien c'est comme
les squatteurs et après et après c'est
vous qu'on engueule et c'est de votre
faute vous faites arnaquer mais c'est de
votre faute Nicolas pernicoff a répondu
il a dit Nicolas pernikov dément
formellement les propos mensonges des
migrants de Monsieur Genton et en temps
rétablir la grille réalité des faits la
société la nouvelle a collaboré par le
passé avec la société blondinet dirigé
par Monsieur Jean tonte et une société
qui s'appelle
du contenu ça fait pas de la coiffure
aussi d'accord très bien et donc alors
bah oui il dément mais il reconnaît
quand même tu l'as des dettes et qu'il y
a ce qu'on appelle en sauvegarde donc
c'est une raison des difficultés qui ont
frappé le secteur de la communication et
de la publicité pendant et depuis la
crise sanitaire la société la nouvelle a
demandé à bénéficier d'une procédure de
sauvegarde afin d'apurer son passif dans
les délais qu'accord de la loi voilà il
parle chinois pour dire qu'il a pas payé
en fait c'est le voilà et ce qui m'a moi
ce qui m'a là où les bras m'en sont
tombés c'est quand j'ai parce que
évidemment quand je l'avais au téléphone
ça va pas c'est compliqué etc d'accord
et cet été quand il met des photos de
lui en train de pêcher la truite
saumoner au Cap Ferret pardon mais c'est
juste une blague ça comme quand vous
êtes voilà quand vous êtes endetté que
vous devez énormément d'argent bah oui
non mais ça il pose ça c'était le moment
magique le moment où je ne pense à rien
bah pense à payer tes factures mec
il a pêché un truc moi j'ai déjà eu des
dettes ça m'est arrivé j'ai tout revendu
je suis allé retourner vivre dans un
tout petit appart et j'ai tout rendu et
voilà et c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais
eu de dettes envers on est bien avec lui
je m'entendais très bien que oui et
justement et le fait que en fait il m'a
jamais payé mais je me disais c'est
quelqu'un de confiance je le connais il
sa société à pignon sur rue il est connu
la notoriété il paye pas et le problème
je me suis fait triplement enfler parce
que je n'ai je n'ai pas été payé de
165000 j'ai déboursé des frais à hauteur
de 120.000 euros pour produire et lui il
a encaisser l'argent mais ça va au bout
d'un moment faut arrêter donc
aujourd'hui c'est quoi il va se passer
quoi là rien mais je sais qui il paiera
jamais parce que la loi est faite c'est
quoi la loi c'est quoi la loi bah la loi
c'est que vous êtes en procédure de
sauvegarde et vous faites traîner un an
deux ans trois ans 10 ans et peut-être
que dans 10 ans il paiera une partie
mais au bout d'un moment enfin c'est
n'importe quoi il y a des boîtes qui
coule à cause de ça non moi j'ai eu la
chance toi les 165000 tu vas te les
carrer déjà sur 11 est-ce qu'on appelle
le bilan à la fin de l'année pour une
société donc vous prévoyez chiffre
d'affaires de temps là en l'occurrence
venant lui c'était 165000 vous déduisez
le chiffre d'affaires donc ça vous fait
un bilan dégueulasse vous pouvez
potentiellement fermer votre boîte donc
ça met en danger les salariés ça met en
danger la société mais est-ce que lui il
aura rien mais est-ce que il dit qu'il
peut pas payer parce qu'il n'a pas les
fautes sauf qu'il a d'autres boîtes
c'est ce que j'ai indiqué dans le
communiqué qui tourne notamment une
boîte qui fait de la télé qui produit
pour pour France 5 et sur ces boîtes il
y a pas de problème d'argent donc quand
on a des dettes comme ça déjà c'est ce
qu'on appelle un un mauvais sac de
gestion enfin une mauvaise gestion de
ces boîtes donc on répartit l'argent on
essaie de faire en sorte de payer ses
créanciers et on enfume pas les gens en
disant en disant oui t'inquiète je vais
te payer plus tard plus tard plus tard
sinon ça dure 15 ans au bout d'un moment
il y a une procédure légale et là il est
en redressement dans ces cas-là les
créanciers comme vous se manifeste
auprès du Tribunal disent je suis
créancier vous inscrivez c'est ce que
vous avez fait mais vous l'avez fait je
l'ai fait et donc vous pouvez pas lui
reprocher de pas vous payer puisque vous
connaissez la procédure je comprends pas
et qu'est-ce qui se passe le but c'est
comme de récupérer l'argent qui
t'explique il se passe rien tu n'as pas
un euro donc au bout d'un moment mais
lui non plus pas un euro sur cette
partie bien sûr qu'il a on a toujours
Gilles lui il a deux sociétés
à ce moment-là dépose le bilan ferme ta
boîte lui sa boîte elle tourne encore et
parfois il nous appelle encore en disant
vous pouvez nous relivrer ça vous pouvez
truc ça va au bout d'un moment
enfin voilà
oui mais parce que il faut le dire et et
il y a plein de gens qui se sont fait en
fumer qui monte qui m'ont raconté ce
soir là aussi et voilà c'est une
autorité publique j'aurais pas fait ça
voilà si c'était une petite somme
j'aurais pas fait ça si c'était euh un
vrai ami déjà un vrai ami ne m'aurait
pas fait ça et voilà quelqu'un qui vous
enfle d'un tel montant je suis désolé
mais au bout d'un moment il faut le dire
voilà je suis et c'est très regrettable
et je ça me ressemble pour faire ça vous
en pensez est-ce que ce que parce que
voilà vous connaissez les deux Valérie
mal à l'aise
de personnes qu'on connaît après je sais
que Guillaume
lui depuis longtemps
c'est que donc j'ai embauché des gens
pour ces projets que je n'ai pas pu
payer tu parles pas des salariés mais
des factures des prestataires je n'ai
pas pu payer et à cause de lui je me
suis retrouvé il y a un compte sur insta
qui s'appelle balance ton agency c'est
une espèce de Mewtwo des entreprises qui
payent pas etc je me suis fait citer par
ce compte en disant l'agence de
Guillaume Genton ne paye pas ses
collaborateurs donc là je les ai payés
depuis mais je me retrouve dans la merde
à cause de lui c'est en fait vous allez
payer avec l'argent que vous n'avez pas
reçu en fait exactement donc c'est
n'importe quoi imaginez Cyril si même si
on est amis même si on est proche si je
vous dois je sais pas 500.000 euros
600000 euros de prestations au bout de
deux ans ça n'arrivera pas voilà
au bout d'un moment l'amitié c'est bien
d'accord quand on se fait enfumer et que
le mec dit oui je vais payer je vais te
payer et qui vous paye pas faut le dire
au bout d'un moment je voulais qu'il
vous en parle mais c'est vrai Guillaume
a été plutôt élégant il a dit jamais
parlé c'est mes problèmes parce que je
pense qu'il y a des gens qui sont forts
avec des faibles les faibles avec les
forts et je pense que si vous l'aviez su
peut-être que ça aurait peut-être
accéléré chose je crois le naïvement
lui faire comprendre que ce serait voilà
j'ai une tête au con non moi j'étais pas
au courant et je suis assez choqué moi
de l'attitude de Guillaume bah oui parce
que en fait vous dites il a d'autres
boîtes mais là vous allez tuer ces
autres boîtes aussi
on doit 10 balles tu vas faire un
scandale
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que c'est disgracieux parce
que c'est tout le business de permikov
que là vous foutez en l'air en ma
communauté
dans la mesure où c'est au tribunal je
vous dis moi ça me choque c'est tout
j'ai été choqué c'est au tribunal donc
des gens responsables peut-être même des
majeurs vont juger
de l'argent c'est aussi payer les gens
payer ses prédateurs et ses salariés
vraiment hyper cohérent pourquoi et
comme les squatteurs
volent ton frigo vole ta voiture volta
femme oui mais il faut aller au tribunal
il faut attendre il est hyper cohérent
en fait Gilles un moment donné un moment
donné moi je savais pas je la
connaissais pas l'histoire je l'ai
découvert avec le poste de Guillaume à
un moment donné il y a quelqu'un qui a
demandé du travail à quelqu'un c'est à
hauteur de 160000 euros cette personne
là a fait de l'argent avec et moi dans
le raisonnement de Guillaume si tu dois
de l'argent à quelqu'un tu as une
mentale soit un homme vend ce que tu
dois vendre rembourser tes dettes et si
tu dois descendre ton train de vie et
revendre tous tes trucs faut revendre
mais faut payer tes dettes et c'est là
que moi je suis d'accord avec l'homme la
loi est mal faite parce que il y a des
gens qui font ça alors là c'est Nicolas
mais ça peut être aussi plein de gens
comme ça qui s'amusent à faire 200
300000 € par ci par là qui ferme les
boîtes et qui rembourse jamais la loi
est mal fait c'est comme la loi mais
c'est la loi
procédure
d'où tu es juges
tu voles tous entre ma femme tu as
compris
il a pas besoin
il a pas besoin il a pas besoin elle
partira toute seule c'est mal fait
Gilles Verdez toi tu étais pas au
courant de la faire mais tu n'aimes pas
qu'il est mis ça sur les réseaux sur la
place publique c'est les réseaux oui les
réseaux la page Facebook parce que
Nicolas pernicoff a d'autres sociétés
par exemple il produit des émissions de
télé et moi j'ai peur que ça lui porte
préjudice pour l'ensemble de ses
activités et que le comme vous êtes
puissant Guillaume j'entends non et le
nom que le nom de permikov soit banni du
paysage audiovisuel c'est ça Macron j'ai
peur qu'il ne paye pas ces salariés
c'est prestataires moi j'ai peur de ça
j'ai pas peur que ça lui nuise à son
business à lui au bout d'un moment il
faut être responsable c'est c'est
pourquoi tu prends toujours la défense
des gens malhonnêtes c'est pas possible
ça c'est insupportable genre malhonnête
c'est pas m'excuser de mettre en fumer
quand même alors on donnera le droit de
réponse
avec plaisir nos versions sont les mêmes
il n'a pas payé c'est d'être lui il dit
sauvegarde c'est vrai en attendant
l'argent il est pas là donc au bout d'un
moment alors l'argent surtout surtout
avec un pote surtout avec quelqu'un que
tu côtoyais tout le temps ici
on a pas 36000 occasions dans la vie de
ce comporter en homme voilà moi l'année
dernière j'avais des problèmes financés
je payais plus mes loyers c'est pour ça
que je suis parti dans le sud comme ça
parce que j'ai plus les moyens de vivre
à Paris payer mon loyer du coup j'ai une
tête de loyer là et ben je me sens
engagé voilà ça me coûte j'ai fait un
échéancier alors on fait beaucoup
d'émission
bah c'est parti la partie du 10 octobre
j'avais je paye une échéancier sur en 5
fois je règle je dois à peu près 12
13000 € Simpson et ben je les paye ça me
coûtait pratiquement tout mon grosse
grosse partie mon salaire mais je mets
un point d'honneur à payer
pas le locataire je le connais un peu la
personne mon logeur je l'ai jamais vu de
ma vie mais je vais payer mes dettes
voilà je vais estimerai je pourrais pas
me regarder dans la glace tant que
j'aurais pas payer mes notes mais Gilles
j'ai bien compris que tu voulais
respecter la loi et c'est très bien
évidemment on veut tous respecter la loi
et le process de la justice mais
t'arrêtes pas dire le pauvre Nicolas
pernicov en fait et pourquoi pas le
pauvre Guillaume Genton en fait c'est à
dire malgré tout en quoi ça
fragiliserait plus Nicolas pernicov que
Guillaume Genton Guillaume Janton lui
aussi se fait du souci il est angoissé
la déni blanche il a des loyers il a des
salariés si ils sont si des gens en fait
il licencie des gens donc oui c'est pas
grave mais permis coffre c'est grave tu
vois il y a un problème malgré tout tu
comprends moi donc du coup je je
n'arrive pas à quel moment tu as eu le
déclic parce que c'est vrai que le mec
sur les réseaux à un moment qu'est-ce
qu'il y a eu un coup de nerf tu t'es dit
ça y est j'en ai ras le cul maintenant
en fait c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé parce que c'est ça c'est quoi
cette école je vais je vais le dire à
tout le monde et je vais le mettre sur
la place publique que Nicolas pernicoff
et moi on a un litige le déclic je l'ai
eu sincèrement en voyant cette photo je
me suis dit quel culot à la photo mais
quel non mais quand tu es endetté que tu
dois de l'argent à tout le monde et des
grosses sommes d'argent on parle pas de
15 euros ou de 100 euros comment tu peux
mettre ça alors ok il dit pas regarde je
dépense des milliers d'euros il va pas
s'arrêter de vivre aussi bah non mais
c'est pas un minimum symboliquement
quand tu dois de l'argent tu écris les
dettes et même quand il venait ici je
sais même pas comment alors je sais
qu'il y a plein de fois il est pas venu
mais il y a des fois il est venu il y a
plein de fois qu'il a il a pas voulu oui
mais comment tu peux te présenter sur un
plateau avec une personne face à toi à
qui tu dois des dizaines et des dizaines
de milliers d'euros ne même pas en
parler qui venaient de voir et même pas
c'est moi qui relancé tout le temps
c'est c'est aussi un peu gêné et alors
et alors vous dites à quel moment j'ai
le déclic moi au début je disais rien
normalement les factures c'est 30 jours
45 jours donc on a un mois deux mois
pour les payer 2 mois 3 mois 4 mois je
dis rien 5 mois 6 mois et au bout de 6
mois c'est même pas moi c'est ma
directrice de production qui s'appelle
qui me dit Guillaume franchement c'est
chaud là il paye pas il commence il
continue de commander des trucs et au
bout d'un moment il me l'a dit Guillaume
arrête maintenant arrête parle-lui
demande-lui un échéancier donc lui il a
fait ça ils ont présenté un échéancier
ils ont payé une échéance au bout de la
deuxième là je suis désolé je peux plus
te payer mais c'est quoi c'est comme toi
c'est quoi ça part en 1h j'aurais pas
été content ce qui est écrit 3 bars qui
vont finir en sèche-chimie c'est bon
elle est bonne la gamelle dans sa
réponse surtout il menace de t'attaquer
ce qui est ce qui est bizarre parce
qu'il dit oui mais qui est vrai il
menace d'attaquer moi je m'en fous
depuis non je lui ai parlé juste avant
de mettre le truc je dis quand est-ce
que tu comptes me payer il me dit ouais
c'est compliqué au téléphone non je lui
ai envoyé un message
[Musique]
mais c'est toujours moi qui suis revenu
à la charge mais voilà il faut un
minimum d'honnêteté intellectuelle quand
tu dois de l'argent tu payes il y a pas
de conciliation
qui m'a fait déplacer avec son avocat et
mon avocat pour dire nous ne pouvons pas
de payer euh voilà donc on va faire un
plan de sauvegarde merci et donc en fait
je me suis déplacé
je ne peux pas vous payer non mais
également non mais soit vous êtes droit
soit vous êtes pas droit nous séries on
travaille ensemble depuis des années on
est droit tous les deux c'est vrai et si
j'avais pas été droit avec vous ou vice
versa on aurait arrêté de de des potes
et des travailleurs ensemble au bout
d'un moment il y a une éthique à
respecter après je dis Gilles en fait ce
qu'il dit c'est que quand un mec a des
difficultés voilà oui il peut pas s'il
peut pas payer il peut pas payer voilà
complètement pour l'enlever
et vous connaissez mon train de vie il y
a quelques années j'ai eu des
difficultés j'ai tout réduit dans mon
agiraline je parle tout le temps
je suis pas allé faire le malin cet été
je suis pas allé c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est pas vu d'ailleurs je suis pas allé
faire le malin à Cannes j'ai rendu
toutes mes caisses
en partie à cause de lui parce
qu'attendais 200000 balles c'est pas en
fait ça fait un trou de 300000 balles
voilà plus les autres il a vendu toutes
mes bagnoles je vivais dans dans dans
350 mètres carrés je suis retourné dans
30 mètres carrés voilà non mais faut pas
faire le malin au bout d'un moment tu as
des dettes tu as des dettes et par
contre je paye tout le monde tout le
monde voilà c'est tout il faut être un
faut être un bonheur au bout d'un moment
on attend prochainement voilà bah on va
on va espère que Nicolas va Vienne voilà
et en parler voilà qu'on en parle et
qu'on qu'on crève la psy quoi j'en ai
ras le cul
l'histoire d'argent quand je monte
l'argent pourri les gens imaginez vous
vous êtes en deal avec un d'entre nous
et on vous doit 165 kilos
viens dormir chez vous chez toi il
attend tranquillement on trouvera des
solutions vous inquiétez pas voilà
j'espère que ça va s'arranger parce que
c'est vrai que Guillaume et je voudrais
dire Guillaume voilà c'est c'est ça t'a
fait mal ouais ça m'a fait mal et puis
on dit que c'est une mauvaise même euh
voilà bah ouais et puis c'est des
personnes en lesquelles vous pensez
avoir confiance en fait pas du tout et
c'est ça qui est pire c'est qu'il y a
des gens en fait vous avez des appréhens
on vous dit c'est comme si je disais bah
voilà c'est Cyril Hanouna il est connu
il va me payer etc et en fait
non mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ouh là malheureusement
pour cette télévision ce mec-là va quand
même me payer bah non tu as confiance et
les petits mecs qui ont rien et qui ont
des petites boîtes voilà eux on les fait
chier mais eux ils payent en fait c'est
ceux qui ont beaucoup qui payent pas bah
c'est dégueulasse voilà
juste kiki est au courant de la vérité
que Géraldine c'était vraiment la
confidente de Guillaume je suis sa
petite maman et toi tu as dit non tu
fais rien tu fais rien non au moins
encore une fois je vous l'ai dit je lui
ai dit dis-le à Cyril il peut peut-être
arrangé aller lui parler
te conseiller et il a dit non non c'est
mon problème je vais pas je veux pas
m'aider Cyril là je ne voulais surtout
pas l'humilier parce que je sais que
c'est humiliant je suis pas du tout fier
de ça je sais que c'est nul de faire ça
et je je souhaite à personne afin que ça
arrive à personne et je trouve ça
moi-même je trouve ça nul ce que j'ai
fait et quand vous ne pouvez plus et
quand au bout d'un moment on se fout de
votre gueule ouvertement bah c'est la
seule solution et j'en suis désolé mais
c'est un coup de merde j'ai eu un coup
de merde bien sûr et qui m'attaque si je
veux m'attaquer en diffamation il y a
pas de problème et vous verrez que c'est
moi qui finirai par payer
c'est c'est généralement ce qui est ce
qu'on voit à chaque fois ici sur le
plateau
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris du temps
en fait non mais en fait en fait on voit
que chaque fois quand les choses
viennent ici et ben ça se résout donc
malheureusement enfin non heureusement
pour toi
avance et c'est pas des des très bonnes
nouvelles gilet Michel et c'est vrai que
la venue
de Zoé lundi a fait rebondir les choses
et amener de nouveaux éléments pour le
moment on va rappeler l'histoire et
réécoutez bien l'histoire parce que
c'est vrai quand vous nous avez parlé de
l'histoire lundi il y a deux trois
petites choses qui ont fait tiquer
notamment Jean-Michel et d'autres
personnes qui étaient chez eux
samedi 23
cette jeune fille Lina quitte son
domicile l'habitat la plaine c'est un
diamant un petit village pour se rendre
à la gare de sainte Blaise la roche où
elle doit prendre le train à 12h03 pour
rejoindre son petit copain
Tao qui l'attend à Strasbourg
elle disparaît sur ce chemin et c'est
d'ailleurs le petit copain fameux Tao
qui va donner le qui va donner l'alerte
qui va signaler à la famille de Lina que
Lina n'est pas arrivé à la gare de
Strasbourg et à partir de là la
gendarmerie va engager du personnel pour
faire des recherches on arrive à cibler
à peu près le l'endroit où enfin à
partir de quel endroit elle a disparu
c'est à dire entre la gare et une partie
du trajet qu'elle avait déjà fait je
crois qu'il lui restait 900 mètres à
parcourir pour arriver à la gare et
depuis elle s'est volatilisée de
nombreuses recherches ont été effectuées
ils ont les gendarmes ont
fondé pardon les les deux étangs enfin
plusieurs étangs ils ont organisé des
battues et pour l'instant toutes les
recherches sont restées vaines alors
justement ça rebondit depuis
une équipe de plongeurs de Strasbourg
ont réalisé des fouilles dans deux
étangs sans rien trouver Margot une amie
lina a dit qu'elle n'était pas comme
d'habitude elle était super contente de
la Strasbourg rejoindre son copain à
partir du moment où elle m'a dit je vais
partir d'un coup je n'ai plus de
nouvelles précises c'est ce qui a dit
Margaux d'habitude elle faisait beaucoup
de vocaux pour parler et là d'un coup
elle écrivait très rapidement c'était
très inquiétant et ce n'était pas comme
d'habitude on le sentait quand elle
parlait c'était très inquiétant parce
qu'elle m'était même des ponctuations
alors que d'habitude elles n'en mettez
pas forcément ce qu'elle dit Margot
c'est ça une des ce qui sous-entend que
c'est peut-être pas elle qui répondait
et qui utilisait son téléphone
exactement alors vous allez voir comme
ça rebondit parce que il y a des
éléments qui sont arrivés qui sont quand
même assez troublant selon le point les
enquêteurs en sont sûrs Lina n'a pas
éteint n'a pas atteint l'étang du breu
ça c'est sûr donc elle n'a pas atteint
parce qu'il y a une caméra installée
près de ce plan d'eau privé qui
appartient à la société locale de pêche
qui a montré que l'adolescente n'a pas
passé les barrières derrière lesquels se
poursuit la piste cyclable donc ça c'est
un élément déjà on sait
Nina aurait donc disparu sur la route
départementale que vous l'avez dit entre
son domicile et l'entrée de la piste
cyclable ça représente combien de de
kilomètres j'ai pas la distance il y a 2
km 9 entre son domicile et la gare et
lui restait 900 mètres à parcourir donc
alors il y a des révélations justement
du nouveau détective vous êtes du
nouveau détective et le nouveau
détective à lâché plusieurs bombes sur
leur site et sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui on va revenir point par
point sur ce qu'ils ont sorti plusieurs
infos qui s'aiment le doute sur le
profil de Tao le petit ami de Lina Tao a
19 ans il s'est installé depuis peu à
Strasbourg en tant que Compagnon du
Devoir qu'est-ce que c'est quoi ça
va c'est
je sais pas exactement ce que c'est
c'est j'imagine que c'est un
c'est des artisans de très haut niveau
de très haut niveau
à exceller dans leur métier merci
Jean-Michel merci alors il vient de
Marseille il s'est mis en couple avec
Lina
15 ans depuis début août début août donc
c'est assez récent
ça fait un peu plus d'un mois qui sont
ensemble et première info du nouveau
détective qui est assez troublante
on apprend que Tao le petit ami Lina
aurait perdu son téléphone dans une
usine désaffectée en cherchant Lina
l'appareil serait moins
longcontreusement tombé dans une bouche
d'égout alors à côté de nous c'est
effectivement ce qui ressort de
l'enquête de ma consœur Sixtine le père
elle a elle est sur place elle est
toujours sur place et elle a fait une
enquête une bonne enquête une belle
enquête et elle a retrouvé des témoins
et notamment elle a cette information
il aurait participé
Tao en réparticipé aux recherches et à
l'occasion de ses recherches il serait
monté sur le toit d'une usine des
affectée et alors qu'il était en haut de
ce toit son téléphone serait tombé
malencontreusement dans le soupirail
dans un soupirail il y a cinq points
vous allez voir un qui pose problème le
premier donc c'est la même mystérieuse
perte du téléphone j'ai dit pourquoi le
téléphone est essentiel et ça perte
fondamentale là c'est important c'est
parce que le petit ami dit qu'il est
parti donc du domicile de la maman de
Lina et chez Lina au matin il va à
Strasbourg il attend à 12h53 à
Strasbourg sur le quai selon lui Lina
elle n'arrive pas et c'est lui qui
téléphone à la maman pour lui dire je
suis inquiet Lina n'arrive pas donc ce
téléphone il doit à ce moment-là borner
à Strasbourg pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
pas un hasard incroyable une coïncidence
qui fait que alors que on va savoir aux
bornes ce téléphone et bien lui dit
qu'il le perd donc les enquêteurs encore
une fois il y a pas du tout de il est
pas du tout mis en cause pour le moment
mais les enquêteurs vont vouloir savoir
si au moment où il appelle la maman il
est bien à Strasbourg c'est ça voilà
mystérieuse perte du téléphone c'est le
premier point très très important il y a
5 oui ça le fait que le téléphone soit
tombé n'empêche pas de borner le service
de police ou de gendarmerie de de voir
le burn-out en revanche pardon en
revanche on n'a pas le contenu des SMS
c'est ça qui est plus embêtant si je
peux me permettre l'expression donc le
téléphone disparaît on sait
on arrive à retrouver de façon très
précise les horaires des échanges qui
appelle qui
qui décroche qui décroche pas et où sont
les différents protagonistes
c'est-à-dire où se trouve Lina et où se
trouve Tao sur ce premier point
très important il y a un point qui est
important quand la procureur s'est
exprimée très rapidement elle a détaillé
les fêtes etc et elle a dit donc Tao
avait appelé depuis Strasbourg la maman
pour dire que Lina n'était pas arrivé
elle n'a pas dit en Verbatim intégrale
que Tao était sur le quai de la gare
donc pour le moment pour le moment les
enquêteurs comme il y a de la vidéo
surveillance à la gare Strasbourg vont
examiner voir s'il était bien sur le
quai à l'heure qu'il indique voilà
deuxième point très important mais nous
et à 5 points qui posent problème là
autour de Tao le petit ami de Lina après
voilà pour l'instant il y a rien de fait
mais on va vous donner les 5 points
selon une autre source Tao aurait
affirmé avoir participé à une batture
avec un certain Bryan un ami de Lina et
visiblement ce serait faux c'est un
mensonge qui a son importance alors ça
c'est embêtant d'autant que Bryan et
très proche de Zoé qui est venu sur ce
plateau
effectivement Tao affirmé avoir
participé à une battue et dit qu'il
était aux côtés de Brian et Bryan quand
il est entendu dit que il n'a pas de
souvenir d'avoir vu Tao alors ça peut
être dans la confusion dans l'adresse
mais ça commence à faire quand même un
sapin voilà potentiellement son jeu de
Tao troisième point
le jour de sa disparition Lina ne devait
rejoindre Tao que le soir mais au petit
matin changement de plomb Taho aurait
appelé la mère de Lina pour lui demander
de la réveiller pour qu'elle prenne le
train et le rejoignent ça c'est un point
c'est incroyable là on comprend plus
hein
il est il habite à Strasbourg il vient
passer la soirée à la plaine en
compagnie donc de Lina il passe la
soirée ensemble ils dorment ensemble il
part très tôt pour un mystérieux
rendez-vous
il est convenu qu'il se retrouve le soir
donc elle a toute la journée pour faire
ce qu'elle a à faire prendre le train et
le rejoindre dans la soirée à Strasbourg
et là changement de programme pour des
raisons qui m'échappent il appelle la
maman donc Fanny la maman de Lina en
lisant réveiller votre fille il faut
qu'elle prenne le train il faut qu'elle
me rejoindre rapidement à Strasbourg et
c'est ce que la maman va faire elle
réveille sa fille et ensuite c'est comme
ça que la fille que Lina va prendre la
route à pied la fameuse D350 là pour se
rendre à la gare et elle disparaît sur
le sur le trajet donc on comprend pas
pourquoi ce changement de programme quel
est ce rendez-vous mystérieux à 7h du
matin qui l'oblige à partir à 7h du
matin et pourquoi tout modifier c'est
encore deux points qui pose problème je
voulais donner dans un instant Gilles
par rapport à ce troisième point j'ai au
contraire de c'est nous ce qui sont sur
place me disait qu'il y a une quand même
Tao il s'exprimait beaucoup et à plein
de gens il a dit oh là là ce weekend on
a un programme extrêmement chargé on a
plein de choses à faire etc il
détaillait un peu d'une manière
inconsidérée et les gens comprenaient
pas pourquoi tout un programme de
week-end comme si c'était un programme
fondamental alors qu'il y avait rien de
très important donc les gens se sont dit
c'est bizarre de détailler comme ça un
programme pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait ça
voilà quatrième point qui pose problème
et ça nous concerne
en apprenant que Zoé la collègue de Lina
a les témoigné dans TPMP ta polio Tao
lui aurait dit fais gaffe si tu dis de
la merde
et il paraît qui voilà c'était un peu
chaud qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
exactement ce que vous venez de dire
Zoé a révélé que Tao l'avait entre
guillemets pas c'est pas forcément faut
voir enfin c'est toujours très délicat
de de parler pour les autres mais ça
existait cette il a décroché son
téléphone et il l'a entre guillemets moi
je prends dans les patins je dis qu'il
la menacé mais c'est une menace j'ai dit
pas de la merde fais gaffe c'est une
menace donc cette jeune fille est venue
et courageusement elle a incroyable elle
a expliqué son amitié avec avec Lina
avec beaucoup d'émotion elle a rien dit
de elle connaît pas en fait elle est
comme tout le monde elle ne sait pas ce
qui s'est passé
et c'est vrai que c'est curieux que ce
jeune homme alors soit il est très
maladroit
soit il y a autre chose on voit pas ce
qui peut le gêner dans le témoignage si
ce n'est si ce n'est que Zoé elle est là
à la sortie du travail à 19h le vendredi
quand la voiture de Tao vient chercher
Lina donc est-ce que lui se dit elle va
dire que j'étais là elle va préciser des
choses et ce qu'il a peur de son
témoignage et ce qu'il ne est-ce qu'il
craint que Zoé en dise plus aux
enquêteurs voilà en tout cas c'est
agressivité bizarre aujourd'hui
ça c'est même pas de la présomption
d'innocence c'est qu'il est pas du tout
mis en cause simplement
il y a des mecs
du tout exactement il y a des faits que
l'on expose voilà selon le cinquième
point selon le reporter de nouveaux du
nouveau détective sur place les
gendarmes ont quitté précipitamment le
restaurant où il se trouvait suite à
après un coup de téléphone cet
après-midi sur monter en vitesse dans
leur véhicule et ont quitté les lieux
pour retourner sur la RD 350 le chemin
sur lequel Ina disparu donc ils c'est un
truc de fou
aujourd'hui ils ont une info ils ont été
appelés ils sont partis au gyrophares de
ton Giraud
et a priori ça n'a pas euh on a
l'impression que les gendarmes font
semblant de continuer les fouilles pour
ne pas trahir le fait qu'ils ont qu'ils
aient déjà un suspect sérieux dans le
viseur ou une voilà une personne
possible c'est tout à fait possible
maintenant
moi je rappelle quand même que il y a
une série de coïncidences qui cible
un individu ça arrive que c'est pas la
personne aussi mais c'est pas bon parce
que il y a cette série de coïncidences
que pour autant ça en fait il a pas été
effectivement placé en garde à vue pour
l'instant il sera entendu très
vraisemblablement il a déjà été entendu
mais il sera probablement réentendu et
on verra on verra bien mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a quand même une série de
coïncidences troublante alors juste ce
rebondissement cet après-midi
voilà les gendarmes se sont précipités
comme s'ils avaient venaient avoir une
info oui parce que il y a eu un appel à
témoin qui suffit des dizaines des
centaines de témoignages de gens qui
n'ont rien vu et c'est important aussi
parce qu'ils ont dit nous on était là et
on l'a pas vu passer à tel endroit donc
ils sont en train de raccourcir les
lieux et de voir à quel moment elle
aurait pu monter dans une voiture parce
que c'est la thèse qui prédomine pas
d'accident la fugue avec le battage si
jamais c'était volontaire on suppose
c'était pas son genre mais qu'elle se
serait manifestée donc elle est sans
doute montée dans une voiture la telle
fait volontairement ou a-t-elle été
contrainte et donc il tente de savoir
sur la route ou elle aurait pu monter
dans la voiture et de chercher partout
des indices voilà oui parce que ce qui
est important c'est que justement quand
elle est montée dans la voiture si elle
est montée dans une voiture on lui
aurait demandé immédiatement d'éteindre
son téléphone c'est à ce moment-là c'est
c'est comme ça
ah oui ah oui oui ça c'est important
c'est très important parce que
sans lui imposer d'éteindre son
téléphone soit il y a eu on peut
supposer tout ce qu'on veut
merci en tout cas Michel est-ce que vous
avez d'autres choses à ajouter non non
pour revenir au départ précipité des
gendarmes vu par notre porter dans un
restaurant je crois
ça arrive souvent sur les gros faits
diverses il y a une vraie tension et un
coup de fil de l'état-major un coup de
fil du patron on sent que l'enquête
avance et ils mettent à ce qu'on avait
dit la dernière fois sur Internet et le
lendemain il y a eu le dénouement nous
ce qu'on aimerait c'est qu'on trouve
Lina vivante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]